janvier 2010 ça me saoule sort les
galaxy s 10 s10 plus on est à lannepax
de samsung autant présenter les nouveaux
samsung galaxy s 10 avec des écrans
poinçonnet ou alors une petite butte le
couvent rendre pour pallier un design
intelligent toujours profiter de ce
moment pour lancer le premier smartphone
nokia qui fut vraiment très attendu le
galsi phone il est là il est beau il est
chaud jus présence
le galaxy folle avril 2019 ils ont
étendu la gamme à en supprimant la
gabegie qui était jusqu'à présent
l'entrée de gamme et la gamme à qui
était le milieu de gamme du coup cette
nouvelle gamme art group
l'entrée de gamme mais également le
milieu cas c'est la nouvelle gamme à la
nouvelle gamme éclat
elle était annoncée dans son intégralité
et danses pleines nouveau produit à 10 e
à 20 à 40 à 70 à 80 et j'en passe et des
meilleurs ça c'est vachement bien et ce
qui est super c'est qu'effectivement il
n'y a pas de bulle pour coup non non je
ne critique pas la bulle je ne suis pas
là mais j'aime pas ta pizza était 2019
samsung lance deux nouveaux galaxy note
galaxy note disent qu'avec six des dix
plus pour étendre sa gamme et touche
toujours plus de consommateurs
vous avez ce joli modèle allongé de
couleur défense assez le modèle noir le
note dispose si vous voyez bien comme ça
je vous mets tout les incrustations vous
allez voir c'est top et là on a le le
note 10 plus septembre 2019 le galaxy
folds refait son apparition ce toujours
galaxie folle un des deux postes et du
des problèmes avec la première version
et on retrouve que possible directement
à l'ifa à berlin
[Musique]
la première version du galaxy paul il ya
quelques temps à paris il a été revu
depuis des problèmes ça vous le savez
est franchement je continue vraiment
aimé ce produit sont vraiment fous la
reprise en europe
octobre novembre 2019 samsung présente
les [ __ ] d'un nouveau tracteur pour
son galaxy paul qui serait en tout cas
le galaxy fold numéro 2 qui pourrait
arriver en 2020 vous avez un grand
smartphone et là vous replier comme
smartphone à clavier fin 2019 il
présente deux nouveaux smartphones en
asie galaxie à 51 galaxie à 71 chambres
et 2020 samsung officialise les galaxies
à 51 et à 71 en europe à 51 et à 71 sur
deux produits extrêmement similaire plus
lancement du galaxy note dit flight ps
dislike le et disney qui n'en parle pas
parce qu'il ne sortira pas en france
écran finity au de 6,7 pouces full hd
plus bien évidemment un écran super
amoled avec une résolution de 2400 par
1080 pixels avec 398 pixels par pouce on
a bien évidemment est ce qui fait tout
l'adn de ce produit en espagne en
espagne qui est connecté en espagne que
vous allez pouvoir utiliser comme sur le
9 10 et 9 10 plus pour télécommander
directement vos smartphones par une
année d'innovation de prise de risque de
concept complètement innovant tout ça
pour recentrer la marque et faire face à
la concurrence
bilan des courses samsung leader sur le
marché de la téléphonie mobile devant
powell et apple 2000 va s'annoncer
tunnel est tout aussi excitante avec le
lancement de pas moins de trois nouveaux
produits dans la gamme s
un changement de nom on sort du régime s
9 aces vitesse disent on va pas sortir
le reste on passe directement os 20s 20s
de plus on regarde le non plus et s20
ultra comme ça on en voit la vache
monitoring terrible là ça bouge pas
c'est mieux quand ça tombe pas il y
aurait même le lancement d'un nouveau
galaxy folle un ou plusieurs galaxies
folle parce que la gamme falls games et
qui va évoluer avec un produit dernière
et pourrait y en avoir plus tôt cette
année il pourrait y avoir un gala qui
fold d2 comme celui connu la dernière et
pourrait y avoir un galaxy folle de 2
aussi on suivra tout ça pour le suivrai
très prochainement parce que le
lancement le gros
se fera le 11 février à san francisco on
en reparlera quelque temps donc si ce
n'est pas déjà le cas les invite à vous
abonner et activer la cloche comme ça
vous serez tous auraient pu tech et tous
un nouveau produit de samsung
mais avant toute chose qui vous montrer
à quoi devrait ressembler le nouveau
samsung galaxy s vous parlons du design
d'alors design intéressant parce que
c'est des fuites qui viennent du site
owni luc sais pas si vous voyez là voyez
il ya plein de filles qui sont marqués
plein de civils fuient tous les grands
construction en tout cas c'est des
choses qu'on voit que ça s'intéressent
alors qu'on voit et ce qui est cool
c'est déjà dans un premier temps qu'on
va retrouver un petit écran poinçonnet
si la voyez le petit point sont je
pensais qu'ils allaient disparaître et
je suis un peu embêté parce que vraiment
j'aurais aimé qu'en face à thoune ne
fassent disparaître ce poisson et qu'on
se retrouve avec la caméra situé sous
l'écran
mais non elle est là est toujours
présente bon peu tu es pourquoi pas par
contre ce qui est intéressant c'est pas
tant du côté de la face avant parce
qu'elles valent reste un petit peu dans
ce qu'on avait l'année dernière en terme
de design démentons très fin des
smartphones toujours bien léché des
écrans incurvés c'est ici au niveau de
la caméra arrière entre retrouvé avec
plein de caméras
si vous expliquez ça dans quelques
instants un obus photo rectangulaire un
petit peu comme ce qu'on trouve au
niveau du pixel 4 de google à peu près
dans cette typologie de produits qui
marchent plutôt bien on l'a également là
dessus voyez là c'est un peu différent
voyez il nous le présente comme ça avec
le flash led qui est là il a été déplacé
en tout cas même si c'est pas exactement
la même chose ils sont tous d'accord
fait dire qu'on va avoir un poinçon fait
qu'on va voir un écran incurvé des bons
extrêmement fins sans le fait d'avoir un
positionnement d'appareils photos sur le
côté il ya même des documents qui ont
été sortis ça c'est un smartphone qu'ils
étaient photographiés en train de
s'allumer en voyait bien samsung galaxy
s 20 + 5 g il a même eu un screen qui a
été fait au dos alors regarder si vous
regardez bien ça c'est assez drôle
confidentiel pas de photos ce smartphone
qui parfait pour la vente si quelque
chose qui doit absolument pas sortir
devant aucun ligue de support pour
koussa a été loupé ses sorties et ce
qu'on voit ça c'est intéressant on
retrouve une fois de plus ce module
rectangulaire ici et surtout c'est le
nombre d'appareils photos qu'on va
compter on en a 1 2 3 4 et s'il envoie
un petit cinquième en saura plus à la
caméra tough message aux expulsés dans
quelques instants
une des grosses nouveautés cette année
devrait venir de l'écran tout cas des
écrans testera plusieurs smartphones et
notamment avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz alors je
sais pas si vous suivez l'actu tech
je sais pas si ça vous intéresse je sais
pas si vous êtes branché sur les réseaux
d'ailleurs c'est pas le cas je t'invite
à venir me rejoindre sur twitter
instagram et compagnie tout simplement
parce que one + annoncé aussi un écran
120 km à l'est quand d'autres
affranchissement de 100 verte c'est
justement ce qu'on va retrouver dans ces
nouveaux smartphones de samsung
les trois modèles s 20s 20 de plus
une trappe en ont tous les trois un
écran de 100 verte et c'est très drôle
parce que justement qui fabrique l'écran
de one plus le prochain écran on sent
verte
je vous le donne dans le mille c'est
samsung samsung display qui est la
partie écran 2,5 faut donc là ça serait
une capture d'écran qui a été faite du
smartphone d'autre qu une photographie
du smartphone qui nous affichent des
faits qui vont le taux de
rafraîchissement soit 60 hertz qui est
un peu un classique soit 120 hertz
on pourrait se dire ok qu'est ce que ça
m'apporte du 120 hertz mais je ne vois
pas l'ue sont des intrus de la gorgue
pourquoi pas mais en fait l'expérience
si vous regardez et si vous avez déjà
regardé des écrans qu'on peut retrouver
en sens inverse totalement le réseau fon
de ou alors pourquoi pas 80 derrière
avec le one + 7 pro est de 7,3 et
compagnie il faut le voir pour sans
réellement se rendre compte que vous
verrez beaucoup plus de détails vous
verrez plus d'action les choses
paraîtront moins saccadée beaucoup plus
fluide et beaucoup plus agréable à
regarder
c'est ce à quoi vous apportez un écran
120 hertz est beaucoup plus de confort
pour vos yeux et ils vous le marquis 6
alors que vous êtes en résolution haute
l'iran 120 hertz
vous allez avoir des animations qui sont
beaucoup plus réaliste et un scrutin qui
sera beaucoup plus fluide par contre il
vous le marquis 661 vous aurez batterie
qui durera plus longtemps parce que
forcément le sens vannes à consommer
davantage
au delà de ça on va avoir effectivement
des écrans de tailles différentes au
niveau du galaxy s 20 vous allez avoir
un écran de 6,2 pouces full hd + dans
tous les cas sont des écrans dynamiques
amoled pour le s20 plus vous aurez un
écran de 6,7 pouces tandis que pour le
s20 ultra vous auriez un écran de 6,9
pouce pour l'ès 20 de plus et pour le s
bi tra vous aurez des écrans quad hd
alors ce qui est très intéressant c'est
le ratio va changer l'année dernière
vous allez du 19 9e là on va passer sur
du 29e c'est à dire un peu plus long
légèrement plus long saut du quad hd
vous aurez une résolution de 3200 par
1440 pixels alors que si vous comparez
avec un écran d'un galaxy no10 plus vous
avez également du quad hd en 3040 par
1440 pixels
on est devant quelque chose qui est un
peu plus long qui peut être pas mal pour
aller certaines séries au format 21 9
viable bon pourquoi pas mais surtout
pour le scroll pour vous diriger plus de
choses à la verticale ça peut avoir un
sens ici ça me saoule a fait l'impasse
sur la prise jack tord absolument pas de
priziac vous aurez un adaptateur usb c
est prise jack pour venir écouter je
trouve pas ça terrible pour moi le mieux
c'est de prendre des galaxies des
douleurs prendre n'importe quels
écouteurs en bluetooth ça fonctionnera
ça ira très bien je pense qu'à mon avis
on a augmenté on avait du blue tooth 5.0
londres avare de bluetooth 5 points
comme par exemple tout cas aller dans le
bon sens bien évidemment de haut
parleurs stéréo pendant la
spatialisation est ce que vous allez
regarder des séries des films
directement sans utiliser un casque
alors ça smartphone qui sera également
performant avec le panier exynos exynos
1990 que vous allez pouvoir retrouver
dans le monde entier sauf aux us et au
canada où vous retrouverez le qualcomm
snapdragon 865 vous devriez avoir pour
la version s 20 ans va blues 12 giga de
ram et pour la version ultra 16 giga de
ram je me demande quand même ces averses
ont réservé un on aura pas plutôt 8
gigas de ram maintenant qu'un 8 12 16
apparaître en tout cas c'est logique
dans tous les cas 128 à 256 ou 512 giga
de stockage extensible jusqu'à intérêt
grâce à une carte microsd
on joue aussi en réellement grosse
autonomie de grosses batteries ont
commenté sur le vainqueur 6-4 mais les
repéreurs le s20 plus
quatre mille cinq cents millions terreur
est carrément avec le s20 ultra 5000
millions perreur compatible recharge
rapide 45 watts qui vous leur charge en
un peu plus d'une heure
vous partirez de 0 à 100% sans quelque
chose comme une heure et quart de
chargement des évidemment loin que ça
serait ou à lui ait deux basés sur un
android
10 je vous montre un peu ce qu attendu
du côté de l'appareil photo alors ça
serait un petit peu un plan de ce qu'on
arrive au niveau de l'appareil photo sur
le plus gros modèle sur le modèle ultra
avec un zoom hybride fois sans ou
carrément un zoom hybride fois sans
pourquoi pas on va donc qu'on a en tout
quatre caméras une deux trois quatre
mais également cinq ici alors soit c'est
le flash led
why not soit c'est la caméra tough la
times of light
moi je pense qu'on aura plus tôt ça
c'est à dire la caméra principale
le téléobjectif l'ultra grand angle la
caméra teuf et ici c'est votre flash led
normalement la caméra principale au
niveau du modèle ultra et doit être une
108 mégapixels oui sans 8 mégapixels
mais uniquement sur des lustres par
contre si vous arrivez sur le s20 l'es20
plus vous devriez avoir une 12
mégapixels normalement ça devrait être
la sony mx 5 155 en 12
à pixels sans capteur principal
uniquement sur le s20 et le s20 plus en
plus haut niveau lui très bien entendre
vous aurez une caméra de 12 mégapixels
le téléobjectif vous auriez une caméra
de 48 mégapixels avec un zoom optique x
10 est un hybride qui irait jusqu'à fois
sans uniquement sur le s20 ultra tandis
que la caméra tough time of flight elle
vous servira pour notre portrait pour
laisser bloquer pour venir apporter de
la profondeur pour dire vraiment mesuré
pour vraiment avoir le meilleur foudre
arrière-plan après on peut l'utiliser
pour d'autres choses pour dec
intéressant pourquoi pas mais en tout
cas pour la photo c'est vraiment le feu
dans la plan qui va sortir là-dessus
côté selphy on devrait avoir une caméra
de 10 mégapixels et vous pourriez avoir
un mode aussi ultra grand-angle lorsque
vous avez plein d'amis que vous voulez
vous filmer des scènes fille plein de
potes autour de vous mais au niveau de
votre capteur principal au niveau de
votre sang 8 mégapixels vous aurez la
technologie qui voit m et de faire du 4
pixels en un sens c'est à dire que vous
allez prendre 4 pixels indépendamment et
c4 pixels vous allez les regrouper pour
avoir un super grand pix elle permettra
de capter plus de lumière ce qui laisse
à vous sortir à une photo en 27
mégapixels et notamment pour la photo
nue ça c'est vraiment bien côté vidéo
vous pourriez film et jusqu'en 8 k 7800
par trois mille 400 pixels
ça c'est juste énorme et uniquement à 30
images par seconde
sinon vous pouvez monter ici en k2 k3
1840 par 2160 en 60 images par seconde
bon il ya aussi du full hd fait que vous
voulez en tout cas ça c'est vachement
intéressant parce que vous avez des tv
samsung
huit cas dont vous pouvez filmer votre
smartphone vous pouvez l'affiché sur
votre télé alors on verra tout ça on
verra effectivement résultat mais en
tout cas ça fait une jolie promesse un
smartphone complètement compatible 5g
parce que la 5g arrive elle arrive un
peu partout tranquille non doucement à
être en son temps mal finir par être là
donc si vous lâchez ce smartphone vous
allez pas l'acheter pour 6 mois vous
allez l'acheter facilement pour un an
voire un peu plus donc il faut qu'il
soit prêt pour la salle j'ai donc il
faut acheter un smartphone 5g
compatibles soit que c'est ce qu'on aura
ce nouveau galaxy s vin est un plus est
ce bien un ultra lecteur d'empreintes
digitales basé sous l'écran lecteur
d'empreinte digitale n'ont pas optique
mais ultrasonique comme ce qu'on est
dernière avec les issers je sais pas si
vous avez suivi mais lors de mon test
j'avais été un peu 18 je comprends pas
c'est un petit peu de temps c'est
compliqué à déverrouiller ça marche
quand ça veut des fois ça marche des
fois
voyez là ça met du temps et la caisse
qu'il mais voilà j'ai pas complètement
couvert donc je repose mon doigt
j'attends ça finit par marcher le truc
qui a ses dunes
c'est pas très rapides et des fois ça
marche pas il faut s'y reprendre à deux
trois reprises voilà ça c'est vraiment
le truc que je regrette là dessus en
fait ce qui est intéressant avec le
capteur d'empreintes digitales
ultrasonique ses coûts et de mettre à
jour mais d'un point de vue logiciel et
c'est ce qu'a fait samsung il doit
améliorer
ils ont fait des mises à jour est la
vôtre avec un capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui déverrouille est
extrêmement rapidement et ça c'est
vraiment appréciable
je vous parlais du but ou cinq points
tout à l'heure mais y aura également
normalement du wifi 6 alors comme je le
disais c'est un smartphone qui va être
présenté à très très très prochainement
san francisco c'est à dire le 11 février
je vous en reparlerai je ferai un
débrief complet du produit on regardera
vont prendre le testera donc abonnez
vous si ce n'est pas déjà le cas
et à mon avis c'est un produit qui va de
toute façon arriver aux alentours des
1000 euros
je pense que pour le s va être un petit
peu en dessous histoire devenir un petit
peu être pas plus attractif
elles se vendent plus on va passer les
bills euros et sv ultra mon avis on se
rapprocher des allées mille 4005 vous
j'imagine en reste 20 aux alentours des
2 vallées 900 950 euros ça me paraîtrait
assez logique s20 plus 1200 euros lutte
2003 et on va arriver sur un ace 20 il
traque avec le club du top le plus gros
après faut vraiment vouloir ce format
parce que si on effectivement un sixième
but 9 pouces c'est quelque chose qui est
énorme qui prend beaucoup de place soit
dangereux cela qu'elle soit dans une
poche on n'est pas forcément toujours
ultra sympa raconte beaucoup de confort
à l'affichage telle un produit vous
n'aviez plus aux alentours de 1500 à
1600 euros s'il monte sur une grosse
config en 512 géant du stockage g
rippert profite le tarif va être un
petit peu plus coquins alors les usages
on les devine assez facilement vous
allez voir un grand écran qui
complètement optimisé pour le multimédia
donc toute la partie loisirs est
vraiment mise en avant
grand écran on connait la cathédrale de
samsung excellente daltrey mandia
calibre est extrêmement bien maîtrisé et
qui en plus est là pour filtrer la
lumière bleue dobro confort de
visionnage audio de qualité
lorsque vous allez l'écouter comme ça ça
serait vraiment fonctionné néanmoins
pour augmenter l'expérience passée par
un casque bluetooth et là vous allez
sublimer l'histoire on profite bien
évidemment d'un grand écran aussi pour
aller regarder ces réseaux sociaux on
profite effectivement derrière de
performance pour activer la caméra pour
prendre de meilleures photos et
notamment une capteur de 100 8
mégapixels donc battre des grosses
capacités de calcul donc on est aussi là
pour le côté prise de photos partage sur
les réseaux sociaux
un grand écran pour venir scrollé
profiter toujours plus d'une meilleure
expérience immersive une grosse batterie
pour beaucoup d'économistes au cospar ça
nous allait emmener partout avec vous et
vous allez pas vous poser la question
est-ce qu'il va tomber en rade de
batterie oui
non un gros focus aussi fait sur la
vidéo parce que partage vidéo cette
chose qui demande beaucoup et notamment
des réseaux comme thil toc un scroll
amélioré lorsque vous allez bien navigué
sur vos réseaux sociaux grâce à un écran
120 hertz et toute la partie gaming avec
la performance derrière avec l'écran
sont vertes
donc on a un produit qui est vraiment
complet à 360° que ce soit pour le
multimédia ce soit pour le visionnage
que ce soit pour lui ou pour le
multitâche pour lui c'est ce que voulait
en faire avec un écran 6,9 pouces 6 tab
de 7 pouces
vous allez pas faire du multitâche sans
aucun problème on a donc un produit qui
s'annonce est extrêmement complet plan
de performance qui va probablement faire
plein de belles promesses vous avez bien
évidemment vous inscrire parce qu'on en
reparlera pas ce que vous en pensez qu
est ce que vous pensez de ce que je vous
ai décrit est ce qui pourrait vous
intéresser
samsung galaxy s 20s vendent plus s d'un
ultra qu'est ce que vous pensez du faux
remède ultra le très gros formats d
écran énorme toujours plus de
performances est-ce que vous pensez que
ce produit pourrait être fait pour vous
oui non pourquoi mark et moi tout ça est
ce que vous pourriez tenté et si oui à
quel prix c'est vraiment très important
parce que forcément le facteur prix il
est extrêmement important le soin des
produits premium des produits qui
coûtent très cher et aussi est ce que
vous pensez qu'en même temps vont y
présenter des nouveaux galaxy folle et
si oui qu'est-ce que vous en attendez
vous marquez tout ça en main en
commentaire quant à nous on se retrouve
dès demain pour continuer par l'état qui
croyez moi la plaine choses à dire
[Musique]